en esta ocasión tenemos esta variada
integral y bueno la idea detrás es
resolverla por sustitución
trigonométricas y porque se me ocurre
usar la sustitución trigonométricas es
que siempre que veamos una integral de
la siguiente forma cuadrada - x cuadrada
nos conviene usar una sustitución
trigonométricas bueno si nosotros
tenemos este problema lo que nos
conviene decir es que x es igual a veces
el seno de teta porque porque a nosotros
nos va a quedar a cuadrada menos a
cuadradas en donde tan inspector izamos
en la cuadrada me va a quedar a cuadrada
que multiplica a uno menos el seno de
teta y uno menos el seno de teta es la
identidad trigonométricas más importante
que hay la identidad pitagórica y por lo
tanto nos va a quedar a cuadrada que
multiplica al coseno beteta sin embargo
en esta ocasión no se ve tan claro que
tengamos esta forma entonces lo voy a
escribir aquí tengo 8 menos 2 veces x
cuadrada ahora qué les parece si yo
factor hizo en un principio 12 entonces
me quedan 2 que multiplica a 4 menos x
cuadrada y ahora si ya tenemos esta
forma porque es lo mismo
multiplicados al cuadrado y aquí
claramente ya se ve quién es y va a ser
2 por lo tanto haciendo mi cambio de
variable lo que me va a quedar es lo
siguiente x es igual a dos veces el seno
de teta lo voy a escribir aquí x es
igual a dos veces el seno de teta y
bueno ya que tenemos a x de una vez
vamos a derivar lo la diferencia del de
x es igual a dos veces el concepto de
tetas diferencial de teta y ahora sí ya
podemos empezar a limpiar todo esto
porque quién va a ser esto que tenemos
aquí esto es lo mismo que 2 que
multiplica a 2 al cuadrado - x cuadrada
pero quien es x cuadrada ambos es 2 al
cuadrado seno cuadrado de teta entonces
ahora sí voy a factorizar mi 2 al
cuadrado comenzaría dicho yo en un
principio esto me va a quedar 2 que
multiplica a 2 elevado al cuadrado que a
su vez multiplica a uno menos el seno
cuadrado de teta y bueno me va a quedar
2 por 2 al cuadrado que es lo mismo que
8 que multiplica al coseno cuadrado de
teta esto porque uno menos el seno
cuadra beteta es lo mismo que el coche
no cuadrado de teta ahora sí
empezar a sustituir en esta ecuación
tengo pin pero pienso una constante por
lo tanto vamos sacarlo afuera desde
integral tengo el diferencial de x pero
el diferencial de x es dos veces el
coche no detecta diferencial de teta así
que vamos a escribirlo tengo a de x que
es este de aquí pero no no lo quiero en
color azul ante x a su lado y de x es lo
mismo que dos veces el coste no de teta
dos veces el consejo de teta que
multiplica al diferencial de teta de
abajo que tengo pues no tengo en la raíz
de 8 menos 2x cuadrada pero todo esto
era esto de aquí por lo tanto lo voy a
sustituir de una vez me va a quedar la
raíz de 8 pero que es la raíz de 8 haber
factores hemos el 88 lo mismo que dos
por dos por dos y si le sacamos raíz me
va a quedar dos veces la raíz de dos
éstos dos veces la raíz de dos por la
raíz del coseno cuadrado de teta pero la
raíz del coste no cuadra beteta es
simple y sencillamente el coseno de teta
a recuerden tengan mucho cuidado no es
tal cual el coste no de teta es el valor
absoluto del coseno de teta
sin embargo podemos asegurar que el
concepto de teta siempre es positivo
porque puedo decir yo esto por cómo está
definida la equis la equis es dos veces
el seno de eta y si nosotros dejamos de
aquí a teta que me va a quedar bueno
primero voy a pasar el 2 dividiendo
entonces me va a quedar x entre 2 es lo
mismo que el seno de teta y bueno cuál
es la función inversa al seno pues el
ángulo cuyo seno o el arco cuyo seno por
lo tanto teta es lo mismo que el arco
cuyo seno es x entre 2 y esta función
usualmente está definida entre menos pi
medios y medios y en menos pri medios y
medios el coseno de teta siempre es
positivo recuerden la gráfica del coseno
y se van a dar cuenta de que siempre es
positivo en ese intervalo por lo tanto
ahora sí vamos a simplificar conocen lo
que multiplica y conocen lo que divide
se van 2 que multiplica y 2 que dividen
se van una raíz de 2 que está dividiendo
la voy a sacar del integral porque es
una constante y va a pasar
dividiendo también entonces me queda pi
entre raíz de 2 de la integral de las
diferencias de t
pero quién está integrando la diferencia
detecta esto que es muy sencillo la
integral de la diferencial de teta es
simple y sencillamente teta más una
constante de integración y hemos acabado
ahora lo que hay que hacer es retomar la
sustitución hacia atrás sin embargo ya
habíamos despejado a teta y entonces
solamente hay que ponerlo me queda pi
entre la raíz de 2 que multiplica a teta
pero te da es el arco cuyo seno es x
entre 2 ya todo esto hay que aumentarle
una constante de integración otra vez y
entre la raíz de 2 por el largo cuyo
seno es x entre dos más c y bueno hay
algunas personas que no les gusta la
raíz de 2 dividiendo sin embargo si lo
quieren pueden racionalizar y ya con
esto hemos acabado todo está integrada
que parecía muy difícil haciendo una
sustitución trigonométricas realmente no
estaba tan difícil